see i i think that's what's happening
with the attack on titan right now
because i swear to god
everyone is looking for every little
[ __ ] nitpick they can think of
to [ __ ] on like the like the change of
studios right yeah
well i think map is doing a great
[ __ ] job right now and
the amount of like shitty takes i've
seen on twitter when the first episode
aired
i i was streaming the day after it came
out yeah all the comments were like
what do you think of the the 3d cgi
connor and attack and titan i was like i
don't even [ __ ] notice it what do you
mean
yeah it looked gross what do you mean
i'm like it was like two
seconds and it looked fine stop [ __ ]
nitpicking i love
no i love all those shitty takes where
it's like oh it's done but
knowing now that it's done by mapper
instead of uh
uh was it silverly no not simple studio
knowing that it's done by mapper instead
of studio it just it just feels
different
i just it just feels different yeah i
had this image of my head of someone in
their house right they've got like
shingeki no kyogen [ __ ] all over the
room yeah waiting with that popcorn like
yes the moment like the cgi comes on
like
oh [ __ ] this
i knew they'd [ __ ] it up no because what
i want to know is that did they just
forget
what the colossal titans looked like in
season two and three
it looked like absolute garbage compared
to the cg now and just because every
titan's cg now
people like i don't know it's it's just
bad
takes and i feel like it's just because
it's such a
massively popular franchise that i feel
the
new like map doing a great job and you
got a great story anyway
that's that's what i love about
following like those like massive
toxic fan bases right it's just the
amount of [ __ ] takes that come out of it
is just
so entertaining and people like [ __ ]
on the opening as well and i'm like
what was wrong with the opening that's
what people said about the last opening
and now everyone [ __ ] loves the last
opening
i already get it man people just get
angry every every [ __ ] season but i
guess it's because
the problem is right is that someone has
a bad take on twitter and then everyone
[ __ ] clowns on them
yeah that's the only take that anyone
sees cause everyone's [ __ ] clowning
on that guy who's like the opening sucks
was it all colorful although to be fair
the attack on titan like when episode
one came out there was
a lot of [ __ ] dates yeah it was just all
over my timeline i'm like who
who are these because people want
brownie points man and so if you're
running points for one looking like a
clown well that's the thing
right because to these people it's like
people aren't going to see if you're a
clown but
if you if you that one time you get a
successful take that like takes off
yeah imagine the clout you get just yes
it's it's it's like the hot the
science behind hot takes right because
hot takes aren't actually hot takes
it's like saying unpopular opinions
right the unpopular opinions that people
upvote
aren't actually in popular opinions
unfortunately you know
it's it's just it's like people say on
popular
opinions just so they can get brownie
points because it's never actually
if it's an actual unpopular opinion
that's the opinion that people [ __ ] on
you know what i mean you're like
that that statement alone just like
completely negated my let's fight
seriously because that's what that show
is all about
taking unpopular opinions yeah i love i
love that but like
that that's why i have such trouble with
like making a next episode of that
because every time i'm like hey guys
give me your unpopular opinions on anime
the top replies are like i think cabbage
was bad
i'm like really you don't [ __ ] say
mate yeah i remember like because i
there's like voice actors do a lot of
those challenges on twitter they're like
hey man like
what's an unpopular voice acting opinion
and it was like you know
uh i think hard work matters the most
and there's stuff like that and it's
like what do you mean
that isn't what what's even an opinion
that's genuinely good advice
like just do the thing like what's
unpopular about it
that's like the level of like yeah i
don't know man it's
it's what happens it's really weird man